and the reaction was intense
last night on social media when kyler
murray connected with deandre hopkins
for the game-winning hail mary
has been calling it the hail murray
lebron james making it known uh and also
patrick mahomes deandre hopkins is a
monster man and uh you know every time
something like that happens it dusts off
the why in the hell did the texans trade
diana hopkins
i'm eating i'm eating that crap every
day every sunday i gotta eat that
well i understood why they did it when
they did it right and what they were
trying to do but maybe it's not
something they should have wanted to do
maybe you should want to pay de'andre
hopkins when he's making noise about
getting his contract restructured and
getting a raise even though he's got
multiple years left and philosophically
we don't do you know all these teams say
well we don't do that well sometimes you
better do it because your alternative is
you trade him to another team and he's
going to continue to exist he's going to
continue to play you are assuming the
risk
that the player is going to make you
look bad for training him right so they
got they got plenty of issues in houston
right now and uh hey when you make the
head coach the general manager instead
of hiring a general manager and you
don't have a second voice
that is strong enough and has the
football chops and credentials to push
back on something like this i mean
there's talk now that jackie used to be
who's claimed basically control of the
organization is saying to people oh i
should have pushed back on these no
one's going to listen to you jack you
don't you you're not coming to the table
with any juice you can't push back they
needed a general manager there a real
general manager there to push back on
what bill o'brien wanted to do because i
think that's what he needed chris that's
one of the problems of putting all the
power in one guy yeah if you don't have
someone else there you don't have you
know you and i have those disagreements
from time to time and actually we one of
us emerges from the discussion better
off yeah you need to have a strong voice
that can say hey wait you know you may
be wrong here no i mean agreed checks
and balances of an organization they're
important they really are the good ones
have those you know types of
conversations or gms coaches
presidents who can challenge each other
they're willing to accept their thoughts
maybe not always agree
but i think that's where we've seen a
lot of successful ones that kind of have
that staying power
in the nfl they all have that in common
and yeah there was obviously an issue a
lot of issues down there in houston it's
not a good look for them and you know of
course it wasn't a good look for them
yesterday and they they missed the andre
hopkins there's no doubt you're right
but yeah there's issues in that
franchise and we're just we're just
seeing the start of it and we'll see
where it goes
we need to move on to superlatives let
me say this because i feel like this
isn't getting nearly enough attention
the idea that easter b has basically
taken over that team when it came out
yesterday one of the sunday splash
reports that romeo cornell has a good
chance to be the head coach of the team
in 2021
because of the pandemic and it's
harder to
search for that's ridiculous that's
insane
yeah all business is being done remotely
now you don't need to be in the room
with a guy to properly vet and interview
a head coaching candidate but my
immediate takeaway was this is easter b
potentially remaining the interim gm for
another year and if you do it long
enough and you manage to do it well
enough you just end up having the job
and if it doesn't work out you don't get
fired you just go back to being the
executive vp of football operations he's
found an accountability loophole chris
where he can give the test run to the gm
job and uh again if it doesn't work you
go back to being the executive vp of
football operations and you hire a gm
who answers to you so just keep an eye
on what's happening yeah if they do that
very unconventional
they're they're and they listen
romeo cornell like love the human being
where he's at at this point of his
career and where the houston texans are
as a franchise
no
if they if they take him as the head
coach at his age right now
and desean watson young quarterback in
the peak of his prime the defense is not
good romeo cornell is a defensive coach
and you have a star quarterback
that would be a pitiful move as much
respect as i have for him it has nothing
to do with roman canelo has more to do
with the situation the players of the
houston texans uh i i would certainly
think less of them if they did that
and ultimately see this is the beauty of
professional sports or or the opposite
of beauty the ugliness of professional
sports uh
the owner ultimately decides what's
going to go on in his or her shop and is
that's the only audience that matters
it's the audience of one and as long as
easter bee sells cal mcnair on this
approach
it doesn't matter what anyone else says
cal mcnair makes the decisions and moves
forward and he can't be fired everybody
else can be fired he can't be fired
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports